to go back to connections in spy we have
Melissa McCarthy meeting all sorts of
people who are going to come to help her
she meets Aldo who is this seemingly
Italian spy who's working for the CIA
but who's always on the makin seemingly
is always trying to stick his tongue
down Melissa McCarthy's throat her
friend Nancy who's there are helping her
from the basement and Langley shows up
in Rome and and is going to help her
deal with all her missions as she's
trying to retrieve the the nuclear bomb
even Rayna who's is seemingly her
nemesis played brilliantly by Rose Byrne
turns out to in the end in fact be
another ally so in connections is the
part of the movie in which your
protagonist not only is moving outside
their comfort zone becoming a more
actualized more complete person but
they're able to reach out and create new
relationships and on a new basis one of
one of the things that I do want to talk
about in terms of the normal world one
of the things I didn't mention yet is
that in the normal world your
protagonist has flawed or absent
relationships Bill Murray doesn't have a
girlfriend you know he doesn't really
respect women Ben Stiller in Tropic
Thunder his only relationship is as
ancient and even that is just kind of
you know somebody to get him a TiVo you
know to be sent to this this jungle
where he's shooting this movie and of
course Melissa McCarthy has no
relationship she pines for Jude Law but
we can see from an early scene in which
Jude Law takes her out to dinner to
thank her for being such a good helper
as you know back in the CIA basement
that's where he kind of gives her this
terrible crazy cupcake piece of jewelry
because we can see that he doesn't
really see her as as an equal so in the
connections part of the comic hero's
journey is where your character because
your characters transforming your
character is growing and again without
them knowing it we in the audience can
see it but they are still not aware of
it that's when these unexpected allies
and also unexpected enemies can come out
that's the part of the movie where
Melissa McCarthy realizes that Karen
Walker who she idolized who was a star
femme fatale spy at the CIA was really a
double agent
you